Hey Team it’s Charlie and as requested this
video is going to be a history of the Constantine
character in the comics along with an explanation
of what’s going on with the show.
I have seen the first episode so I’ll probably
just post a non-spoilery review next week.
But yes, it was a lot of fun.
Hello any new people, if you’re just finding
me for the first time.
I’ll be doing Constantine videos every friday
night this season, be sure to subscribe to
join the team.
We have a good time.
I’m going to start with the story of how
the character was created and then I’ll
do his fictional biography inside the canon.
The New 52 reboot changed a few aspects of
his backstory, so I’ll try to incorporate
some of those as I go along.
In real life, the character John Constantine
was created by Alan Moore inside the Swamp
Thing comics in 1985, he was introduced as
Swamp Thing’s Supernatural Advisor.
The design of the character was actually based
on Sting, the musician.
The reason he looks like Sting is because
the artists on the Swamp Thing comic were
huge Police fans and wanted to draw a character
that looked like Sting.
So Alan Moore invented John Constantine.
The funny thing about that is that the first
artist to actually draw the Constantine character
was a totally different person.
Rick Veitch drew his debut in Swamp Thing
number 37.
There were all kinds of real life occult things
that Alan Moore threw into the character like
serial killers, the Winchester House, which
is an actual place all piled into Sting’s
appearance.
He did this interview at 1985 San Diego Comic
Con where he explained that Constantine was
turning into something much bigger than a
simple ‘put our favorite musician into a
story’ character.
At his core he’s a character that always
has an answer for everything, has many agents
working for him all at once, seemingly knows
everyone and is constantly manipulating people.
DC was originally very worried that Sting
would sue them for making a character that
looked like him but Sting himself was really
happy about it.
In 1988 the character got his own title, Hellblazer.
Which is what inspired the tv series.
Then in 2011 he was also made a part of the
Justice League Dark team, so he appears in
that title and the Hellblazer comic since
the new 52 reboot.
Justice League Dark for those that don’t
know is just a Justice League made up of all
the supernatural characters like Zatanna,
Madame Xanadu, Deadman and Frankenstein.
Here’s his fictional character biography.
A lot of this wasn’t written into the canon
until the Hellblazer comic started.
Way after Alan Moore stopped writing the character.
He was born in Liverpool in 1953, because
of complications from an earlier abortion.
His mother died giving birth to him and his
twin brother.
Supposedly his twin was killed in the womb
after John’s umbilical cord strangled him.
His father, who had forced the mother to get
an abortion couldn’t handle her death and
blamed John.
Thus they developed an unhealthy father son
relationship from the start.
You can already see, he’s got the origins
of a crazy person.
His family bloodline descended from the Laughing
Mages, a group of mages who had the ability
to trick gods.
Eventually John learned about this and it
inspired him to take up magic.
One of his first acts of magic was to distill
all of his childhood innocence into a physical
box as a literal way to get rid of it.
He ran away from home and started living with
Francis Chandler also called Chas, he’s
being played by Charles Halford in the TV
Series.
You’ll see him in the first episode.
Chas became his best and longest surviving
friend.
Then John got involved with all the big occult
circles in London and eventually started dating
Zatarra.
Started a band named Mucous Membrane and even
released an album called Venus of the Hardsell.
Eventually he decided to play the hero, but
his first act of good was a disaster.
He finds a little girl in the aftermath of
a magical orgy gone horribly wrong.
The little girl had raised a demon to punish
everyone for what they’d done to her and
to try and banish the demon, John raised a
demon of his own.
But he wasn’t able to control it.
So John’s demon killed the other demon and
his friends and took the child to hell.
After which John suffered a mental breakdown
and was committed to Ravenscar Psychiatric
Hospital.
He was in and out of that place for years.
In the first episode we learn all about the
little girl, since the comics have already
closed that saga I’m just going to skip
what happens to avoid spoilers.
But you can imagine.
Before the new 52 reboot he would go on to
be involved in several magical wars and big
occult stories in the UK.
The big difference between the
character in the Hellblazer comics and the
one in Justice League Dark, they’re two
different characters, is that the DC Version
is young and the older Hellblazer version
is in his 60s.
DC Comics explained it this way, the Constantine
of the Hellblazer stories has aged in real
time since his debut.
So for every year of the comic, he aged 1
year.
In Justice League Dark, he’s a young man.
On the TV Series, they don’t really get
into the Justice League Dark stories, but
the do make the character young.
So if you want to read big stories of his
that inspired the TV Series, a couple suggestions
are Dangerous Habits, it introduces the idea
of Constantine having terminal lung cancer.
The movie dealt with this, but the tv show
isn’t really doing it.
Haunted, which is all about a battle with
an evil magician named Joshua Wright who starts
going after John’s ex girlfriends.
Hard Time, this is Constantine trying to survive
in a maximum security prison.
He has to rely on a lot of his tricksterish
ways to get by.
and for some deep cuts there’s Neil Gaiman’s
run Hold Me.
It’s from his early early comic book writing
days.
It incorporates a lot of folklore that Gaiman
has become really famous for.
As a character he does have extensive magical
training, he can even use magic to time travel.
He also has this special ability called synchronicity
wave traveling.
It gives him the supernatural ability to make
his own luck.
Like if you were playing a board game and
your character had a luck modifier giving
you a bonus to your dice rolls.
Constantine can manipulate his own modifier.
He can give himself more luck.
Qhe prefers not to use magical spells unless
he’s in a big battle.
Usually he relies on quit wit to get himself
out of situations.
In the canon, it’s rumored that he’s even
been able to trick God and Lucifer as well
as Superman and Batman.
After the new 52 reboot when he joined Justice
League Dark, he was retconned and given some
more powerful attack based magic.
He also has demon blood running through his
veins, first because of a transfusion from
one of his biggest demon enemies.
And then later sex with a succubus.
The demon blood causes him to age very slowly,
and gives him regenerative abilities.
Kind of like Wolverine’s healing factor.
I’m going to do a review of the pilot next
week but there have been some big changes
they’ve made to the show since they shot
that.
They’re still airing the pilot.
That will be the first episode on Friday October
24th, so mark your calendar.
But here’s the changes.
They re-shot a scene at the end, the big battle
they teased in the trailers.
I’ll explain that during a spoiler section
of my review.
They also replaced the main actress.
In the pilot you guys will see, the female
lead is named Liv.
She’s not a character from the comics, she’s
someone they created for the show.
She’s played by Lucy Griffiths.
You might know her as Lady Marian from the
BBCs Robin Hood and True Blood.
The said they just felt like the character
didn’t work the way they wanted.
So they replaced her in the second episode
with the Zed character from the comics.
She’s being played by Angelica Celaya.
She’ll appear in the second episode.
It sounds a little weird, but it’s totally
normal for a show to recast roles and make
changes between the pilot and the regular
episodes.
I’ll talk about all the other characters
on the show when I do my review video.
But they just cast the Spectre.
They basically have free reign of the supernatural
corner of the DC Universe.
So they will be bringing on a ton of comic
book characters during the season.
Because the premiere isn’t for about 5 more
weeks I’m just going to be doing bonus videos
on friday nights.
Be sure to subscribe to join the team.
I’m doing videos for all the new comic book
shows.
I’ve seen all the first episodes of the
new ones.
Yes some are better than others, but they’re
all a lot of fun.
Right now click here to learn about the deadpool
movie that they’re making now and click
here to learn about the Arrow and The Flash’s
big two hour crossover this year.
Thanks for watching, we shall reconvene for
Doctor Who tomorrow.
High Fives!